it's totally valid to feel like we're in
sort of
fall of the republic territory here
because we are
i mean this is uh you know probably
something like crisis of the third
century if we're comparing
western civilization to rome uh so i
think we probably do have a couple
hundred years
left to go but i think it's evident that
whatever we've been doing to bring us to
this point
is leading us on a path to destruction
are you the most demonetised man on the
internet
um possibly uh
well i mean a lot a lot of people have
also been demonetized so
uh not including the federalists though
apparently
they just had to turn off their comment
section at google's behest
otherwise they would have been but yeah
zero hedge stephen crowder myself
and a bunch of other people count
angular you know we'll get demonetized
because
we say things that are not very
politically correct i suppose
it's happened twice to you now though
right it has so one
what was three times actually actually
four times now i think about it
dude that's the title that title is
it's just because i talk about things
that the progressives also talk about
but i don't talk about them in a
progressive way
and so i'm a bad person
so what's the current makeup of your
youtube
verse at the moment you've got multiple
channels right
yeah the only one i really use at the
moment is a cad daily because i'm
currently setting up a website
um to do the same sort of things through
um and i'll start podcasting
other things after i've done that so i'm
just using this one at the moment
i've got you and then you've still got
the like the old archived one the
grandfathered one
yeah yeah but um youtube have uh
quarantined it in some way
so well and i tested this the other day
on my new channel
i've got 300 000 subscribers and if i
put up a video within the first like
18 hours i'll have a million impressions
and some like 200 000 views um
and on my old channel i put it up and in
the first 18 hours i had about 100
000 impressions and that's got 900
that's got three times the subscriber
base
as my new channel and yet it'll get
something like you know tenth of the
views
and it's crazy because my content isn't
i don't think markedly different my
audience still seems to be there
so it seems very much that the channel
itself has been throttled in some way so
i guess i just have to leave it i love
the idea of a quarantine channel
yeah well it happened to tommy robinson
as well and
it's it's happened to a few um but these
days are just outright taking them down
uh there have been um people who
excuse me um people who are more much
more extreme than me
who uh have been slowly
the the noose has been tightening and
now we've come to
conservative channels because all of the
alt-right or anything like they're all
gone now
they're on different platforms so the
noose is just growing tighter
and you can see that people get targeted
before
they get removed as well like katie
hopkins and milo had their blue check
marks removed for their verification
check marks on twitter removed
which is weird because it just kind of
shows that it's not about verification
it's about privilege though isn't it i
mean milo and katie didn't stop
being milo and katie and no one thought
that they did
you know and since they they were public
figures of note you would think
that it would be important for the
public to easily identify them but
apparently not
there's a warning shot across the bow
then yeah i think uh yeah it is and i
think
i mean facebook actually has an active
list of uh
i can't remember exactly what they call
the list but essentially it just
translates to wrong thinkers
uh i'm actually on it and a lot of other
people were on it who have been removed
i don't know how i still have facebook
presence but i mean i don't say anything
that's that's wrong you know crazy or
even bigoted
or anything like that you know i don't
even make jokes anymore um
because you can't have any fun on the
internet anymore apparently
but increasingly i've noticed that your
stuff appears to be
more and more you kind of treading it
sounds a little bit sometimes like you
are treading on ice
well we are there's very much a sword of
damocles hanging above our heads and
it's fallen a few times and cut me
already
so uh we've got the scars to prove it
yeah
exactly i've got the scars to prove it
that's right um
so yeah i i just have to
have to be the thing that's really
interesting is
the way this all worked out because i i
can't help but notice that you're in
your house in your bedroom uh doing this
and
i began in very much the same way i just
had a one bedroom flat and i was just
doing it in my living room you know
because
at the time i was unemployed so i was
just like well i may as well
and it took off um i mean now i have a
converted garage in my office but uh you
know i started in very much the same
position
and it's interesting how we're being
held to the same
standards as something like cnn or fox
news
you know giant organizations with
hundreds of employees
and we're being held to the same
standards which really makes you wonder
why they need all of that to do their
jobs doesn't it
you know if it's so easy that just cut
you know guys in in their homes can do
as effective a job then maybe uh
maybe there's a there's a veil that
they're hiding behind
this was a point that eric weinstein
made on joe rogan's podcast better than
i've heard anyone make it and what he
said was that
people refer to the mainstream media
now that's what the cnn the bbc's yeah
so on and so forth
corporate media hang on a second if
this podcast me and you joe rogan or me
and you if this gets
100 million views which would be great
uh but if this gets 100 million views
and cnn puts a video up and it gets 500
000 views
whose mainstream media now
now you can call them traditional media
traditional media is a
nice word but they don't want that
because mainstream's a signal
mainstream is we are the arbiters of
truth we are the ones
it is it what what we mean when we say
mainstream
isn't really the view counts and it
hasn't been for a while and that's why
we're being treated as
competitors to them but what they're
talking about is approved
these are the approved media the
approved gateways ratified ones
exactly the people and the thing is
because it is
all a system that interlocks you cannot
sorry you can understand why they would
want such a thing
because it puts them all essentially on
the same team when it comes to certain
issues
uh the for example the bbc they brag
about
how everyone still comes to the bbc when
they want to get you know the
coronavirus information it's like okay
that's true but you are also a
privileged
source because of your access the
politicians
make the platforms as much as the
platforms make the politicians
if politicians wanted they could just
refuse to do interviews with any of the
media
and just do interviews on their own
youtube channels using a smartphone or
something
you know they could say look here's the
questions i want to answer blah blah
blah
thanks very much and then the media
would have to extract from that and then
they would just be
just like anyone else but it's access
that they have and this is
it's a two-way street they there are
it's
from from my time dealing with all of
this and i've
met a few very interesting people in my
time it's very much about
who you know because there's no shortage
of people
there's a shortage of trust and so it's
about making
creating like webs of trust between
people and
and it's very and the thing is i don't
see how it could operate any other way
that's the problem uh because you've got
too many people who are pulling at you
i would say so i think it's probably
inevitable it's going to work that way
but yeah so
essentially when you're someone like me
and you come from it from the complete
outside you know i didn't i didn't have
any of this
um i can see why they hate us
you know there's some guy in his garage
some guy in his garage yeah yeah
and because we can say things they can't
say we can challenge narratives they
don't dare challenge
um and they'll punish us for it that's
what they're doing
i think the long-term move of joe rogan
spotify had a chat with
a guy from podcast notes earlier on who
understands the infrastructure very
cleverly
and he thinks that the long-term
goal for spotify with podcasting will be
something similar to what netflix has
done
that if you signal to all of the big
players get the big players on board
play count goes up easier views are
available on there they can monetize
more highly
then once they get critical massive
podcasters across that's where you need
to go to put your podcast on to get the
plays
then once you're there they can start to
squeeze down the earning potential
now i hope that it's not as orwellian as
that and i also think the one
um the final bastion like the last stand
that you have as a content creator is
you
giving your word that you agree with the
particular advert so the difference in
conversions
on a dynamic versus a host red is huge
it's like
4x basically so joe rogan's saying i'll
i use this i endorse cbd
uh versus it being have you got your new
copy of
learning and housewife magazine from w.h
smith get your first you know it just
doesn't convert as well so i think
that's
maybe the [ __ ] in the armor but that
could be long term you know
yeah i mean this honestly this is a part
of the reason why i'm setting up my own
site you know so i don't have to
be reliant on any one host or anything
like that
um as long as you don't turn into brian
rose from london real
that would make me i don't know who that
is good that
is that is the the most blissful
situation that you could hope to be in
my friend i'll i'll try and keep it
there yeah that would be great
okay so meat of it how would you
describe
2020 to someone that had been in a coma
since christmas
um well i mean it's not really very
different to what i've been saying this
whole time
it's just that here is all come to
fruition i mean it's
it's really weird listening to um
mainstream voices basically sound like
my 2017 videos
and it's really interesting that
essentially everything i was saying
this is not just um what we are seeing
is not just people complaining
about police brutality right this is
fundamentally a communist revolution
that has been brewing
in academia teaching a generation
to think that capitalism and the west is
evil
and this gives the moral license to tear
it all down i mean
a statue of george washington was torn
down in portland the other day
because apparently he was a slave-owning
racist it's like well
i mean you know the united states is
going to be tainted by this original sin
that it can never
overcome ex and obviously we are as well
and so this this just means that these
people have an emotional
um sort of disposition against the thing
that they're attacking
like they they i don't think they'll
ever be able to become patriotic again
because they've been emotionally
conditioned to hate that thing
you know like
they the demands they're going to make
are also
going to be insane which they are like
to get rid of the police and things like
this and
you'll see here people say oh no we just
want to you know police reform [ __ ]
you know the the activists the radicals
the people who are actually driving this
are quite open they want to get rid of
the police and that would be
i mean there have been examples of
police going on strike and it
within hours devolves into an anarchic
situation and
we can see from the chairs or the chop
as they're calling it now
that this isn't exactly a productive way
of life
is it you know we have law and order and
justice you know judiciary and the
government for a reason
as as evil as they can be at times
we still do need them in general you
know
so um basically we have to understand
that this is a communist revolution that
we are watching which is why they do all
the same things as previous communist
revolutions
like setting up a commune you know
tearing down the established
order the statutes of the established
order and they're just very open about
saying they want to get rid of
capitalism
like black lives matter did a fundraiser
in the uk that's probably earned over a
million pounds now it was 750 when i
last looked at it
and on the on the first line it's like
we're here to dimensional dismantle
capitalism imperialism white supremacy
heteropatriarchy and stuff like that and
people looking at nigel farage and
farage is
finally saying well look these people
are actually communists who are here to
take over capitalism
which i was saying and everyone's like
well
you can't prove him wrong can you not in
the first line none of that stuff sounds
to me like the first the best way to
progress black people in this world it's
not the best way to do anything
it's that's the problem the problem with
communism is it's a religion
masquerading
as an economic system like nobody would
want no nobody would question
what side is more productive like when
the soviet union fell
they americans sent economists over
there to do an analysis and they
basically
found that they were earning about half
as much as they could be just given what
they had
it's just that the means of distribution
being centralized and top down
demolish any kind of incentive like when
you take away
the security of the protection of your
own private property
you've got no reason to get up every day
and start building something you know
why would you this can be taken away
from you
and so it's very difficult to motivate
people um
and it's obvious this is the case but
it's not about that what it's about
is establishing something that they can
feel is perfect and moral
because it's all predicated on morality
like it
like they'll say things like capitalism
will never end inequality
well no that's true but inequality is
such a fundamental part of diversity
that why would it even be desirable to
do that if we were all equal we'd have
to be all the same and therefore there's
no diversity like there's a natural
difference there's always going to be
people at different heights and if you
want everyone to be the same then your
only option is the lowest common
denominator
because you can't raise up people who
aren't going to be raised and you'll
have to pull down people
who otherwise wouldn't stay at the
bottom rung um
but yeah so essentially we have to deal
with it in these terms
it's it's a moral crusade that the
communists are on
and they literally don't think there's
anything moral about our system
which they've pathologized as whiteness
even if it's not necessarily white it's
there's a number of black people that
can be on that other side of the fences
if you don't agree with
a particular ideology so how how has
this year
fitted together how do you think that
coronavirus contributed to this or trump
being impeached or the impending general
election the
american presidential election have you
got some sort of conception of how that
fits together does it even all fit
together well
i think that the coronavirus um
i i don't know you get people saying oh
this probably accelerated things so well
maybe i i don't
you know i honestly i don't think anyone
can really be sure of that so i'm not
going to
suggest that's an a causal factor
especially as i don't think it needs to
have been in play to be a causal factor
um it could just be that it set the
stage
but i but the the tinder you know you
know
like but the tinder was already there
you know it was already ready for the
match to be flicked into it maybe it
just packed it more tightly so the
explosion was bigger or something but
like the what what we've been seeing
is the results of a consistent pattern
of activism
from a consistent set of beliefs that
have recognizable
public figures as adherents and thought
leaders
uh robin d'angelo is the person who's
like trending
in these spheres at the moment her book
white fragility was at number one so
it's and it's worth reading
because it's unapologetic i mean i made
i was reading it earlier i made some
notes huh let me just
read you a quick line or something from
it because it's just crazy
um the the
the whole point um
is she thinks she's saying to white
people what people of color can't tell
us
and she views white
culture as being like and
she just says white because it's in the
american context but she's talking about
the sort of anglo-saxon protestant
european culture that america was
founded on because of the
english colonies um she views that as a
kind of
ethnic attack on non-white people
that's what whiteness is and that's what
white supremacy is existing
not not just by existing but yes it is
just by existing but the
it's in the way that it is different to
these other cultures it's
uh individualistic and meritocratic for
example these are the two big pillars
that she
uses about whiteness which yeah it would
be
you would expect that it's it comes from
england which is an individualistic
society
and it's meritocratic because it's a
protestant society it's very
geared around personal hard work uh this
has been a
like a moral tradition
in england you know you you when and it
infects every part of the culture so
like you know when you're poor you're
ashamed of being poor because the
implication
in the english moral system is that
you've been lazy
right it's that you are a free man you
know this is this was the point of being
a free man is that you had control of
your life and if you're poor
that means you're not working very hard
right that's i'm not saying it's the
case
it's just the moral implication of the
thing um
and so that's why the shame attached to
being poor in in english cultures um
but the the the whole structure the the
individualistic memocratic that
is a form of racism in and of itself
that's the racist thing
and that's what white europeans do in
america
and therefore whiteness which is the
desire for an individualistic
meritocratic culture
needs to be destroyed and what she's
doing
is trying to create a kind of white
identity that is effectively laden with
the
presumably catholic guilt that miss
d'angelo has
held over from her her parents and
load this identity onto people saying
look whiteness is a form of oppression
it is inherently racist you need to you
know understand that
you're someone who perpetuated by having
standards by wanting
to be treated like an individual to be
you know to be concerned about
merit to be concerned about skill in the
things that are going on rather than
arbitrary and i'd and expressly identity
politics category she she's just open
saying no i'm
arguing from identity politics for white
people
so in many ways she's actually very
similar to richard spencer because that
was exactly his message
do you want to become a nazi that's your
option d'angelo is offering it and i'm
saying no to that no no way i'm not
becoming a white identitarian even if it
comes laden with guilt
and i have to prostrate myself i mean
this is why this is why you're seeing
you know um
the ceo of chick-fil-a shining a black
guy's shoes on stage so yeah
brilliant shoe shining forced racial
shoe shining that's the path to racial
harmony isn't it
you know i mean that's surely the thing
you're saying that was done wrong in the
past
and yet they're like oh yeah i'm gonna
no we're not shining each other's shoes
okay
we're not doing that that's totally
disrespectful which is what you were
objecting to
you know and so we're not gonna do it
and somehow make record
recompense or reparations out of this
this is humiliating
the thing which has sort of struck me
the most has been how performative some
of the communication has been
from everybody and yes that that no
matter
what your goal is no matter what your
viewpoint is
communication should be honest not
performative
because as soon as you start to do that
you can't tell who the
where the truth's coming from who
actually cares
who doesn't care and all the things that
we
need to talk about most are precisely
the things that we can't talk about
and until we are allowed to have a
nuanced conversation
how do you even move forward i think
you make a really interesting point
about performative uh conversations
and i i totally agree with you i think a
lot of them especially
from the corporations uh for example
discord today
published uh things saying oh we're
gonna do our part against the fight
against
whiteness um and we're going to start
policing
your chats and stuff so if there's
anything we consider to be problematic
we're coming after it we're going to get
it
um and that's really interesting is it
because
like what does that do you know that
doesn't make less racist
it does seem entirely performative and
like you're saying it
if it feels hollow because communication
is usually not done
uh essentially from compulsion
you know like it it seems that these
people are not speaking from a real and
true conviction
it seems they're watching everyone else
thinking jesus christ would better do
something or we're gonna get [ __ ]
uh so here we go and so you've got
because communication when two people
are talking there's
loads of different factors that go into
the
tone and the message you've got the
sense you've got the tone
you've got the actual words spoken the
logical structure the semantic
construction of the sentence there's a
lot that goes into
us communicating and yet when these
people come out and give their kind of
oh we we are for diversity diversity is
our strength
it sounds very hollow and very forced
there's you know there's
there's no human connection to it that's
why it feels like corporate speaking
so much of it's like hostage gun to the
head stuff
yeah to me like i don't know if i was
i was gonna say if i was the head of
black lives matter but they don't
that there isn't uh there isn't a single
figurehead there is they're so
distributed that you can't you can't
deal with someone which i'd love to get
your thoughts on in a second but
like if i was someone who genuinely
cared about black lives matter i got a
guy who works for me who's actually
iffy really cool guy from canada who
said i don't like the way that stuff's
being done over here i've proposed to my
university that i'm going to kind of
take on try and move this movement
forward and i was like man like you know
good luck to you it's gonna be it's
gonna be a challenge but good luck to
you
but like if i was watching that i
wouldn't
think great we've we've got another ally
i'd think hang on a second i don't trust
that person
um yeah i
there's a there's a fundamental
disconnect in the way that the world
views are being approached
and this is like if if anyone consider
themselves uh essentially a conservative
uh this is the thing you really have to
bear in mind
um the the intersectional left which are
the
the people who that that's an umbrella
term that will broadly describe
black lives matter feminism anti-far you
know the
other communists you see on tv um and
people who are parroting the same
talking points in the same way
as them they have a view
of a human being that's just very
different to your own
uh most i i i'm gonna get a little bit
esoteric here but like most people
uh have a kind of unitary view of a
human being the human being is you know
you are your body you have
certain properties that are created by
your body which you strength how high
you are how tall you how [ __ ] you
jump
and it also includes your brain and
people understand the brain's a
biological organ
and that's the source of your
consciousness your will
right and so most people will understand
that there is a biological connection
between what you think and what you are
and you'll you'll notice in
like your moods you know you you see
people when they take uh when they
transition they start taking hormones
they speak about their dispositions the
way they feel
becomes different and that's totally
normal because the brain is a biological
uh piece of uh you know part of an
organism and it's affected by reality
and so most people don't think that the
will
has like this this sacred
sovereignty and the the will is being
constrained by the body
most people just kind of and without you
know without articulating like this but
that's the assumptions that they'll make
is that you know you you've you're
you're all a part of a biological
organism
but if you look at left-wing philosophy
at the moment it's oh i've got this the
wrong way around anyway
um the if you look at left-wing
philosophy at the moment they they take
a totally different approach
like what what is it for a a regular
person
to identify a woman they'll say an adult
human female right
but that's a transphobic definition
because that
means that it can't simply be that a
person identifies as a woman
to be a woman and that's a very very
interesting dichotomy because
adult human female is very much based in
biology it's very much based in
in the presence of a person you know
it's an objective category
i can look and see that you're an adult
i can see you're a human i can see
you're a female
or i could check if maybe um but i i can
objectively determine that however
what you choose to be is
only in your head and it
grants license to the idea that the
thoughts the consciousness are somehow
the supreme
sovereign over everything that's the
most important thing
um and i don't and i realize that
this is a very esoteric way of looking
at it but what that does is it makes it
transcendental it means it's not
connected to the biology the biology is
actually
holding it back rather than being a it
being a product of the biology
and so you end up getting people saying
well if i if i will that i am a woman
one day then i should become a woman and
it's like okay
i mean i i don't know i'm not trying to
be mean or anything
and i know that i agree that gender
dysphoria was
is a you know a problem that a person
has
but that doesn't mean that the will is
just correct you know
we it's it's there is a biological
process
that has not gone right to produce that
result
because an imperfect system but the will
itself
just cause it you know there's
conditions that make it feel a certain
way it's not completely free
and so we can't just treat it as
autonomous right but they are treating
us as a thomas i will that i'm a woman i
will
then this i will not say yeah okay you
know you can say that but
you know objective reality has a
different opinion
and the the the big schism between the
two
is whether you are a kind of person who
believes in objective
reality which means we're rooted in
biology and rooted in
things that we can touch or are we
actually
you know sovereign wills that are
trapped within this fleshy form
you know so that's i i i realize that's
probably it sounds silly to people who
aren't really thinking deeply about all
of this but that's essentially
the philosophical basis i think the
manifestation of the will the
manifestation of that inner soul somehow
that is
what it is yeah um well just to explain
very
very yeah like it comes basically from
continental philosophy and it it comes
essentially from the idea that the will
that there can be a perfectly good will
and a perfectly good will can only be
something that's not contingent on
reality because it would
have to be true in all times and places
basically um
and that it's a it's a very uh
continental way of looking at it and
it's not a very british way of looking
at it
it's a very idealistic way of looking at
it uh but the
the english-speaking world has always
been very empirical
uh and not really given to tremendous
flights of fancy
um and that's essentially the major
difference that we're looking at here
and so it's not a surprise that the
english-speaking world is looking at
this thinking what the hell is going on
because it doesn't make any sense to
them you know it's
it's it's uh it's annoying frankly
what's your views
on the recent removal of faulty towers
german episode
um it's been decades since i've seen it
but if i recall correctly wasn't that
mocking racism
like wasn't that the point i'm not sure
i'm absolutely certain that the point
i i i guess it's been decades since i've
watched it but i'm sure
the point of the episode is to mock some
guy who is being
racist all the time and to show him as
being the backwards buffoon that he
clearly was
um but yeah nothing nothing safe and you
know what's interesting is who asked for
it
who asked for them to take these things
down you know
this is this is the very interesting
germans don't strike me as the sort of
group that are vetting i don't know what
i don't know the german culture that
closely but they don't strike me as the
sort of social justice type uh
there's probably a bit more social
justice in there than you think
really um oh yeah i lived in germany for
eight years like
they're they're quite systematic
thinkers um but it wasn't germans that
got it pulled it wasn't even because of
germans
uh it was because the guy said the
n-word in it um
because in the seven yeah yeah yeah yeah
made in the 70s
so i don't remember that happening i'm
sure i'm i think i'm sure he did i'm
sure he did i like his
comments below yeah yeah it's been
decades since i've seen it i'm sure he
says the n-word in it
but that's part of the ridiculousness of
the character you know that's part of
what you're meant to be laughing at
um but yeah it wasn't it wasn't german's
got to pull down but it was got it was
people who were
un aware that the mob on twitter
has certain trigger points and one of
those is
the n word the other one is blackface
you know
so a bunch of things were taken down
that had people doing blackface and
again
the joke is not the expense of black
people it's the expense of the character
doing the blackface but it doesn't
matter the context is all gone now
i don't know if that matters both
selector was shite when it came out
yes like that should have been taken
down for just being [ __ ]
like forget forget the implications of
social media that's whiteness that's
white meritocratic view isn't it well
avid marion was just wank
like regardless regardless i never liked
that
a man like how dare you how dare you
make your career off the back of craig
david who
it must have murdered and i know for a
fact that he's had a conversation with
lee what's he called the fellow the avid
marion guy the guy that's like three
layers behind the person that was
yeah craig david that guy um and uh
then craig had this amazing a resurgence
of a career like what sort of four or
five years ago or something like that
did that song and then justin bieber
remix and blah blah and now he's selling
out ibiza doing all this stuff
but his career make no mistake about his
career stopped
because of that character yeah that's
why his career tanked like
forget the social justice side of stuff
that's one man
bearing the brunt he's the tip of a very
very very long spear
right and he's bearing the brunt of all
of that like that is [ __ ] disgusting
that's the thing that's terrible
about it like think about all the jokes
that craig david had to go through i had
this flourishing career this young
mixed race uh r b artist fantastic good
looking guy really good voice blah blah
blah
and then just some fella decides again
regardless of race could have been a
black guy could have been a white guy
could be an asian guy
decides to do that like that's
absolutely scandalous but that was
allowed on tv at the time
how do you get something passed that is
targeting
one person well that was why john barnes
said he
saw no problem with it at all it's
making fun of a particular person he
wasn't making fun of a race or anything
but again now with with this new
framework of
the idea of whiteness uh there's no such
thing
like everything that we do is inherently
racial
uh to these people so uh no none of that
sort of stuff is going to be made
anymore you know so
this this is over now yeah is this just
the new world because i'm being honest
like
again i don't want my empathy is sort of
fairly crippling and i don't want
something to be on tv that makes a group
of people feel uncomfortable
like if if it was if that was the sort
of thing that really does make
a big swath of the population feel
uncomfortable then
i like have it for the people that
should have it on dvd
or whatever you know the same way as
sacrilegious books or whatever back in
the game
don't burn the books but in the same way
facebook doesn't put pornography on
curate the message for the audience and
don't put it in front of people who may
not want to see it
i'm sure is this the new world now have
we permanently brought the guard rails
in on the type of content that's going
to be produced publicly
um yes until there's a
uh counter-revolution the the social
justice types are revolutionaries openly
so they'll tell you i mean bernie
sanders
has been leading this and he's been
calling it a revolution he
wrote a book called our revolution you
know
i mean he's not nearly down as far down
the rabbit hole as these people but
he's still part of the same movement um
and they they're very
they love communist revolutions because
the idea is there's gonna be an amazing
revolution
we'll establish the perfect order and
therefore history's over we can carry on
living as however we we choose
um the essentially there's gonna like
and it looks like all of our
institutions have fallen to this it
looks like every company because
there's no solid defense against it
because
essentially you would have to make a
defense outside of the logic of the
thing and nobody seems to be prepared to
do this
like every every conservative should be
standing saying look
i'm not making a commentary on black
lives matter
as in as much as i am objecting to the
moral framework
that black lives matter is built on you
know i don't believe
in racial collectivization i don't
believe that we should tear down some
because of the others and i don't
believe that we can ignore bad
actions for good intent you know the
actions matter
we're like i say we but generally
like i guess what we'll just call the
right wing is very procedural
you know how you get to where you are
the
the
means are what justify the ends and they
really are on the other side the ends
just to find the means
this is why they don't care if they're
burning down cities like
thousands of businesses have been burned
and looted in america in the past month
thousands it's crazy in 40 cities
there's a part of a city that's been
taken
over by communists and i'm just like
there's just no not one thing burned or
looted is justified you know but
to the people who are supporting it and
this is everywhere this is newspapers
this is left-wing politicians this is
corporations
so the people supporting it they don't
care you know they don't care about the
damage that's been done
and that's that's the the the schism at
the heart of the whole thing
and then while this order is in place
it's going to act exactly as you would
think it's going to drive towards
moral perfection like this abstract
moral perfection you you can already say
now who was it
someone someone who did blackface uh in
a comedy skit
like 10 years ago i i can't remember
which one it was one of the like late
night comedians
or someone like that yeah someone like
that it wasn't him but it was something
like that
they were saying they were taking like a
year off or something it's like oh
really
at the time when the blackface video
resurfaces exactly so i mean exactly
i i don't really the thing the thing is
this order is going to continue
and it's going to continue establishing
itself until essentially it becomes
untenable
but this this group of people on the
other side who think well actually
we think that a plurality of views and
behavior matters
um until they conduct their own kind of
counter-revolution
and either not just take back the
industries or
create new ones um then it's going to be
the social justice regime from here and
now and you can see on
the on twitter at the moment the things
going around at the sky
sky cinema where they're like this this
uh like i can't remember exactly how it
is but essentially this film was made in
a different era
and may contain scenes that are
disturbing to the people and it's
basically you know it's for everything
even like the 2019 aladdin reboot
is now problematic that's quickly making
pejorative statements about people from
arabia
i don't even think it is like i watched
it i didn't i didn't see
anything with the little bells on the
end or anything like that
but that's not is that bad well i don't
know this is the thing
right the meaning but i don't know i
don't know i don't i don't know so
variety
i asked you this varieties 10
problematic films
that need disclaimers and discussions
before and after watching
and they're now on skype uh skye
sorry no they are in this list dirty
harry
forrest gump indiana jones and the
temple of doom
me before you once upon a time in
hollywood which only came out last year
yeah and then children's hour the
searchers so they're from the 60s
forrest gump 1994 dirty harry 1971
indiana jones 1984. i think that one was
was problematic because it showed hindu
people as being the
ones that can take your heart out uh so
yeah i mean
this it's the circular firing squad
though obama was talking about now
culture is going to be cleansed and
when people do this there's a way it's
also competitive
right there's a way there is a way of
attaining status by doing this by taking
the scalp
you get to brag and say well look i just
aided the revolution
you know we are slightly closer to the
social justice future because indiana
jones has been censored
because head on a spike exactly head in
the spike and
and this taking things down becomes
competitive sport
you know everyone's looking at everyone
else getting kudos and thinking well i
need to do something you know i found
something
and so these campaigns will intensify um
until someone just says well look i just
don't agree that this is a problem
really if i'm the one that's controlled
like no it's not everyone's terrified
yeah and rightly so like the silence is
deafening stuff so crossfit i don't know
what you've seen that the crossfit ceo
put his foot in it in a really really
huge way they hadn't i didn't they
hadn't decided to
put out a message when every other
company was
during that period that like five day
period they didn't do that the black
message with white writing
um they didn't have one of those and
then greg glassman the ceo did a thing
tweeted um there was a little bit of
nuance to it
when you dug in deeper but it was it was
just a stupid tweet
like and when you think of the current
environment it was as as basically as
stupid as you can get
and now he's resigned and that is that
is tumbled out there's no way that that
wasn't going to happen
there's no way that wasn't going to
happen and you know from my side i think
yeah he [ __ ] up like see you later on
greg like you're off mate
but there has to be a line somewhere
with what we do with culture and with
what we allow in from history
people that [ __ ] up right now i'm like
look mate you you're an adult
you know but you can't judge
the situations of history by the
standards of today
however yeah you you wouldn't because it
would be irrational to do so
it's the searches made in 1956
yeah should that be condemned for it
okay no that shouldn't that should be
taken down
okay let's roll the clock forward at
what point
does doing a thing which today is
reprehensible but back then was
acceptable
become due
recompense in the now because no one's
going to the people that made the
searches in 1956
and saying we need your head on a spike
let's get rid of your blue tick on
twitter
yeah but okay so at some point where the
children's are in 1961 or
indiana jones it was the guy in indiana
jones harrison ford harrison ford
harrison ford's head's not on a spike uh
harrison ford isn't really responsible
you'd think they'd be going after george
lucas for writing it yeah but my point
is like
there's but they will there's a there's
a line
somewhere and i just want i want to try
and work out
where that is because once we have
something definite
something a guideline that you can work
with you can be like okay
i can respect the boundary that has been
set
i can ensure that there is a rule
whereby
we do not make people in this in this
world feel uncomfortable but for as long
as there isn't a rule
you can pick and choose that's good
that's bad that's good that's bad
joe biden says in one sentence that it's
uh racist for trump to not uh let
chinese people in and then two months
later
says that the lockdown started too late
yeah like
multiple things being true at once is
yeah i think i think
that the desire to find consistent rules
is uh in in some ways foolish
because it it comes i'm not trying to be
insulting or anything i i i spent years
struggling with that too right um it's
it's
and and so i you know i was foolish to
think teach me expedite expedite my
progress through
yeah yeah well once you realize
that they're going for revolution you
realize okay well revolutions are
effectively wars
you know you're talking strategy and
tactics disposition of the troops on the
field whatever the
whatever the field the battle is you
know it could be magic the gathering or
something
you know dungeons and dragons you know
or playing card games or you know video
games or whatever
it could be hollywood movies whatever
the field of battle is you've got
uh people who are more powerful than
others and
and they they make moves and
your side wins your side loses and once
you realize that and
it all of social justice requires
power to be defined with it what's
racism it's power plus privilege
right that's uh power plus prejudice
sorry
um that's that's not the definition of
racism we use but that's the social
just all of these words are defined
contextually in a schema of power
and once you realize that you realize
that there's no
point trying to be
morally accurate in to what you've
already said or to your own principles
right
um because you're not trying to
establish fairness
you're trying to win you know so if
something's benefited my side
yeah right anyway yeah i mean it's not
it's not any cost they do have they do
have
limits to things that they'll do and
they won't do uh but those limits are
way outside of the boundaries of what
someone like you or me
might find acceptable you know burning
down business small businesses that's
totally within these limits
you know but uh you know insulting a
trans woman
of color on twitter that's totally out
of limits that's not going to do it you
know
so they've just got very different
standards um
what was it going to say harrison
[Laughter]
no the the the battlefield uh right yeah
so
this is why you see joe you know joe
biden can say one thing
when it's advantageous for his team and
then the complete contradictory position
when it's advantageous for his team and
none of his team will call him up on
that it doesn't matter mate that
that blows my mind the fact that you can
help someone who can reverse their
position
say a thing and then within months say
another thing
these people are supposed to be the
leaders of public opinion the pinnacle
of how we deliver the will of the people
to the the upper echelons of the most
powerful country on the planet
how on earth is that allowed to happen
because it's the great and good doing it
they're the ones with their fingers on
the levers of power aren't they
like it should be the sort of thing that
people scream from the rooftops
like these aren't elected
public officials but it's like how is
there not
how does this allow you to trust and
that's not me to say trump's any better
you know trump trump says
trump's got a myriad of failings but
trump is not a revolutionary
he doesn't want to overthrow the
american republic he doesn't hate the
founding fathers he's not going to tear
down any statues
he's not going to do any of he's not
going to defund the police
you know he's not going to increase drug
and crime rates you know things like
like trump has got so many failures but
being
in favor of the concept of the system
is not one of them you know he's he's at
least on that
whereas the left hate the system they
hate what it is how it's founded in
their view
and so they they're going to do so much
more damage than trump would ever even
conceive of doing trump like again like
trump
actually seems to care about fairness as
stupid as that sounds
when charlottesville happened and he was
like look i'm not talking about the
nazis even though cnn always cut that
bit out
but on both sides of the argument there
are good people that's a fairness
issue you know if he if he wanted he
could have said yeah the
the proud or sorry not the proud boys
the um the nazis charlotte phil
you know the protesters did nothing
wrong antifa did something wrong
if he wanted it would look terrible you
know a fair-minded person like hang on a
second
you know they're both bad at this site
you know and that you know
it's not just one or the other and so
when they when the media when cnn when
the democrats say all evil lies in the
opposition
you know that they're not playing for in
in the ideal of establishing a fair
uh playing field or how to say not not
just playing field just atmosphere
a society that's fair given the fact
that we have this
crazy covert situation that's just
happened everyone's got
heightened emotions heightened intensity
their time on site has been increased
they haven't got to see the people that
they love they're scared about catching
a pathogen which is like
evolutionary wired into us to be
something to be afraid of
so you've got this uh ambient anxiety
right this low-level ambient anxiety
that just sits in the background
then on top of that you have this
constant news cycle which this year has
just been
trump got impeached this year
yeah this year which features no one
cares which feels like 80 years ago
it does no one cares so you've got
you've got that's happened you've got
the the news which is being uh either
misrepresented
uh distorted either purposefully or just
due to the fact that they've got to try
and keep up which means that there's
going to be
willful and just accidental negligence
going on
uh then all of the george floyd's
situation
you've got the subsequent subsequent
riots you've got
and then you've got the upcoming
presidential election like this is the
time
where we should be trying to be as
precise as possible
with the things that we say as honest
and as truthful as possible because
any slight deviation from that will be
magnified and then when you add
layer upon layer upon layer like people
that getting all of their truth from
twitter
like just from some guy on twitter and
the fact that you can now do that and be
a story which
people start to repeat and becomes part
of the canon
like it doesn't surprise me that this
situation that when you fully reflect on
2020
it doesn't surprise me that we have this
level of inflammatory discussion
people talking past each other and just
total
the performative communication
everything it doesn't surprise it was a
long time coming uh the the twitter
stuff i find really interesting
uh because it's how it's affecting the
media class
uh there was a leaked uh memo from the
daily beast where the
the high ups were trying to what they i
think was they were forbidding the use
of twitter during office hours
because they felt that twitter and it's
just i think broadly more
broadly accurate that twitter itself is
actually
doing damage to the journalistic
profession
because yeah i mean like like yeah
the the the and fake news is
being widely perpetrated by it like for
example when the
football lads went to defend the statue
of churchill
the fake news surrounding this and the
misinformation surrounding this is quite
staggering
the claim that they're nazis is not true
and the proof of this is in the fact
that we're protesting against
a statue of winston churchill being
damaged gary lineker or like you know
some of the famous football tweeted out
going
why are these nazis trying to save the
statue of winston churchill it's like
well that's
the very fact you're asking the question
means you need to do more research
doesn't it gary
you know you should have looked in this
guy okay well hang on are these nazis
and they go oh no they're doing nazi
salutes and it's because there was a
side on uh picture you could see people
putting up their hands both hands like
this because they do you know they did
this clap
chant in the thing and they were
chanting england but from the side oh
you you can see how that might look like
a nazi salute
but that was and even people like julia
hartley brewer were
like repeating this and then there was
another fake bit of footage where
someone had
imposed over them uh the audio of
some uh white nationalist or national
front protest from like
2017 where they're chanting we're racist
and we like it
and this was again repeated everywhere
on the radio on lbc
i hurdled and it's like that wasn't true
you know the
the football lads there are many
failings again like with donald trump
you know many ethical failings of what
they've done
however they aren't nazis they are
actually kind of like you know the
post-world war ii british patriots you
know
they firmly believe that britain's role
in the war was a good thing they firmly
believe in winston churchill's
leadership
and they firmly believe in the narrative
that we were on the site of
side of right and not on the side of the
nazis and yet there they go oh look at
these nazis
i can't hear what we can do you know did
you see
the map of voters
in the uk that was shared just after the
general election
and it had who voted by age and it went
hyper viral on facebook and it basically
showed
that um the implication was
old people voted conservative that's how
boris got in power did you see this
yes that became
not only not only something that people
thought but
fully bullied like it was straight fact
and it was a map taken from 2017
2016 i think
really i didn't know that yes
see it's amazing how this stuff goes
viral and then creates the fake news
but it's just like some guy some fella
you know or some girl from
bristol you know salford and
it like it's it's it was a fact but not
in this particular circumstance
but again like the fact that that is the
way
that the culture develops now should
terrify
everybody no matter what side you're
coming from yeah
so social media has been a curse that we
weren't ready for
um and i mean it's probable that
something similar to the effect that
we're seeing now would have happened
given enough time i think it's probably
inevitable uh given the philosophies and
you know them percolating through the
culture probably would have done
but i think social media is just
essentially an accelerating factor
that's just got everything to go so much
faster and like there was a study that
showed that twitter
activates the same parts of the brain as
being in a fight so when you get on
twitter you're in
fight mode oh no totally you might not
be moving but your heart's pumping
your adrenaline is going your brain is
is you know as you're like
arguing with someone on twitter you may
as well be going and have a fight with
that person so it's like okay
you're essentially stepping into the
world's largest fight club when you log
into twitter
and get ready to get punched because
everyone gets punched on twitter you
know what i mean
and so it like it's just
it's not good what do we do like well
the the problem is that the
the interpretation of the facts uh
diverging is fine everyone expects a
divergent view of the interpretation of
the facts
but because people are sat in their
online echo chambers
and there can't really be any other way
of doing this apart from
having it so that you don't get to
choose what you follow
because when people get to choose what
they follow they follow the things that
they like
and that means they only get that
perspective one you know one view and so
it was that there was a plurality of
opinions on the same facts
but now there is not there's there's
divergent facts for each side
and i really wish when kellyanne conway
said other alternative facts
it was like haha there's no such thing
as alternative facts like yeah there are
there are facts you're not listening to
you're not paying attention to
like you know despite being 13 you know
that's a fact
that you didn't want to mention it's an
alternative fact
it's still real and yet you leave it out
of the narrative and so
it's you know it's it's it it's now at
the point where we don't even agree the
same things happened
you know these yeah the the the london
bubble is like oh they were nazi salutes
people with video cameras didn't capture
any nazi salute
these people do not profess to be nazis
and they wish the defender was a
churchill
what do we do well in the meantime
i don't know i don't have all the
answers obviously but one thing that i
do
is i make sure that even if i hate it i
watch information from sources i don't
agree with
and there are a bunch of sources that i
really don't agree with and i've found
even more insufferable but i've
continued to force myself
to watch these things to get you know
they'll watch certain people's coverage
of certain events to get the other facts
to get the other facts
what are these what would you say so
let's say that i am which i am
a person who wants to try and at least
get a broad cross-section
of what's going on what would you advise
that i read and listen to
well i mean the the most obvious place
starts like though if you're gonna watch
the mainstream news um watch
fox news and msnbc and you'll hear
two sides of the same narrative that
will include facts that the other one
didn't include
so you will learn things from both sides
and that's essentially what you've got
to do on any subject any any given event
so i find myself you know watching like
david pakman or novara media
and at the same time watching sean
hannity and tucker carlson
and i i mean like i don't really like
fox news i don't really like any of the
personalities other than tucker
carlson's i think he's actually
on the money a lot these days um but
basically you've got to find yourself a
sort of list of people on either side of
any
political debate who you find tolerable
that you can watch even if you disagree
with them
you've just got to figure it out you
know and you've just got to accept that
they see the world differently to you
but you still do need to have both of
those things this is something that um
hayek uh pointed out in the road serfdom
the the dangers of totalitarianism the
reason that totalitarian societies
become like they are is not because of
propaganda
in in every society there's propaganda
it's just in a liberal society
there's a plurality of propaganda
pulling you in all different directions
so you're introduced to all different
kinds of things so you don't ever get
okay i've only heard one thing
so i really that's reality and that's it
you know because you see
something so messy that it's almost
impossible to work out what's going on
well no no no no no no it makes it
impossible to work out what's going on
it means it's
much more difficult to find yourself in
a political cult
where you've only heard one side of the
story you've never heard the other side
okay so you can still
you know you can find out what's going
on from all this plurality of sources
it's just you won't be radicalized to
one particular worldview or the other
um and it's it's not that it's not wrong
for people to have
their own political opinions they put
out obviously everyone's free to do so
um the danger with totalitarian
societies it creates radicals and
crazies who are zealots for the system
because they only ever hear one thing
and so the other people must be evil
and our social media feeds are doing
that for
us so it's really important that we
remember that we're not 100 right and we
are actually kind of self-radicalizing
and we've got to try and
decondition ourselves we need to
take everything that we read with an
increasing pinch of salt but the problem
is now as you've identified
the old bastions of truth
that we would be able to rely on a long
time ago they're no longer there
because they also have an agenda and
they also have pressures and
they also get stuff wrong and like so
yeah
again layer all of this on top of the
worst global pandemic in a hundred years
and everyone being locked in the house
and
heightened tensions and emotions and
stuff like that thirty people died in
the black lives matter protests in
america
thirty people died like there was videos
of guy you know this one guy got beaten
unconscious then his teeth kicked in
just as he's laying on the floor someone
punts him straight in the face now watch
out i was like
you know and you know 30 police officers
in london were injured at the black
lives matter protest and then another 20
when the football ads went down you know
again i'm not going to say that it's
only one side that's done or anything
like that you know but
but if i were a partisan on either side
i absolutely would and the bbc and sky
news absolutely did make it sound
as if the black lives matter the mostly
peaceful protest the injured 30 cops
you know like that you see the video of
the horse running down the street
yeah yeah because someone chucked a bike
and rocks at it and stuff like that and
then it knocks
it knocks some pedestrian over man yeah
like
that's that's the thing as well like i
feel
even with this channel like i'm i feel
like i'm treading on ice with
everything that i say and i'm like i
don't i want
i know that i have reasonable views i
also know
that there are people out there that
require sense making to be done
anyone that's listening the two best
podcasts that i've heard on this is sam
harris's can we pull back from the brink
which is phenomenal sense making and the
most recent brett weinstein and eric on
joe rogan which was also fantastic
if you listen to those two
uh pieces of content it'll take you
maybe five hours in total i think
but you will be in full possession of a
bunch of facts
and a bunch of opinions and sam's final
piece on his podcast which i absolutely
love is where he says
can we imagine a society in which the
colour of your skin was treated the same
as the colour of your hair
that would be an a racial society
and a race agnostic society and to me
looking at what's happening at the
moment this is so much more divisive
than it is uh cohesive right and
the thing which makes it feel so like it
was so close
or at least i felt like it was so close
right at the beginning of this
pandemic i had uh dr eric feigl ding he
used to be an advisor to the world
health organization on really good
episodes just like look tell us about it
and the one thing that came up to me
there was it doesn't even rain
everywhere on the planet at the same
time there are very few things which
unite humanity
globally in one turn very few things
that remind us and there was that famous
quote i think it was
um like one of the mid 70s presidents
that said
can you imagine how quickly we would
forget all of our terrestrial
differences
if we had a threat from an alien
civilization wasn't that reagan
who said that i don't know someone but
my point is my point is that when you
are
as a species as a as a humanity
is facing this threat you do combine
together i know
what lockdown in wuhan kind of feels
like
i know what the f you're a little bit
different but you get my point like i
have
something there's a shared human
experience absolutely and i was like
at the beginning of this the first thing
i thought or one of the first things i
thought was
wow this really could be in a very
bizarre sort of way something that
unites us
something that creates a globe which
actually appreciates what we are as a
species
you know and just how tenuous our grasp
on
existence is and it felt to me
like look this is kind of getting there
and then yeah i i that sounds too
optimistic to me
i i don't i i think the worst uh sorry
the best that the coronavirus could have
done
is just delayed and it probably did you
know this this
maybe would have happened you know three
months ago if it wasn't for the
chronovirus
um but the the these unresolved tensions
man i can
it's totally valid to feel like we're in
sort of
fall of the republic territory here
because we are
i mean this is uh you know probably
something like crisis of the third
century if we're comparing
western civilization to rome uh so i
think we probably do have a couple
hundred years
left to go uh but i think it's evident
that whatever we've been doing to bring
us to this point
is leading us on a path to destruction
something's wrong
right yeah something's wrong something's
deeply wrong
um this was probably uh built into the
enlightenment
uh which i i'm not i don't relish to
have to say
because you know i i'm a product of it
and i believe in the ideals
but you have to be honest about the
things that are going wrong and these
people are pushing for like absolute
freedom and they seem to be wanting
to destroy everything that we have it
took a long time to get to this position
and it was very
a lot of hard work from a lot of good
people and i'm not prepared to call them
all bad people because the moral
standards have changed
you know that's and it's unacceptable
it's it what's really insulting about
that
is it's essentially saying that the
roman empire's army could never have
learned to use guns
right because we don't like morality
develops
over time you know we there there's a
time when literally no one on earth
questioned the institution of slavery
why would you what the hell are you
talking about
you know and then there became a time
where people did start questioning it
then it came a time
where it was essentially like a moral
revolution where we're like no there
can't be any slavery
you know then it and democracy comes no
everyone should have the franchise why
should these people
say okay this is great and it's the same
as developing this you know so we're
saying that like people back in
you know the 16th century or whatever
you know
if they had been raised now or you know
introduced to
our ideas our concepts they couldn't
have believed
that actually that they were so innately
deficient that they
they had poorer morals inbuilt into them
not that they were just a product of
their environment
exactly which is amazing for the
philosophy that views everything as a
political
contextual battle you know but yeah
exactly
you know they are the product of their
time you know that's what
what do you expect most people end up
representing the societies in which
they've been
raised and their society had normalized
moral standards that we think are
terrible and it's only because we've got
a different society that everyone agrees
you know
and so it's it seems to be doing them a
great disservice it's
awful it's it's a jordan petersonism
where he talks about how
um people that believe that if they were
back
in maui china or in stalin's russia that
they would have done it differently that
they would have behaved
differently and it's like you would have
to be an
extraordinary human
for that to be the case and if you're a
determinist then you know
well yeah yeah but i mean but no but
that's that's exactly the point it's
like why
why would you think that they wouldn't
react
rationally to the pressures that have
been put on them right because they they
are they you know
it's a rational reaction in the in the
situation that they're in it might not
be a good one
but you'll you'll when you're in their
place you'll see why they took those
decisions and
depending on the kind of person you are
you might take them too
that's then there must be an element of
this
on the other side of the fence though on
the black lives matter protesters
that have a small minority who have
tried to
potentially hijack this movement to move
it toward
ends that the vast majority of people
that are supporting it
don't actually want and then they're
kind of getting dragged along and
they're again they're products
of perhaps the the loudest the most
machiavellian
i don't know how it works and the main
oh no you you're spot on that's exactly
how it looks the main problem that
i can see is that without a single
leader for black lives matter
from a distributed leadership
we can always continue to move forward
perspective that's great
but from a negotiation perspective so
that you can actually start to
move forward productively with the rest
of the world
like who do you talk to yeah there's a
problem with
um the sort of secular religion that
has become uh the the the radical
left-wing
essentially it is all an aspect of
communism i would say uh
the the idea of borders and boundaries
of
how have they adopted or how have they
uh internalized this like who's who's
giving it to them
um people who are very clever
people who have been training for this
this is people have been studying for
this
for their whole lives i mean this is
what robin d'angelo is talking about you
know this
they're very very carefully thought
about these things and
they're very good at laundering their
ideas through other ideas that are
totally reasonable
you know we want police reform totally
reasonable that means defund the police
totally unreasonable you know like
there's there's a
there's not only one way of doing it um
i was going to say something else very
quickly then as well
but i've forgotten what it was so yeah
got it um last thing mate
how would you advise someone
communicates now moving forward in a
productive manner do you have
a way that you try and do that um
don't be a hero because these people are
on on edge
uh there's blood in the water and they
they will come for you you know they'll
do as much damage to your life as they
can and they'll feel justified in doing
it
um they they will ruin you if if they
can
so don't be a hero um
but if it's something that's really
bothering you and you you feel
tremendously motivated to do something
there are lots of um
people who are trying to push back in
lots of different ways
and you can do your part by like you
know buying their book or buying you
know
the t-shirt or whatever it is that
they're doing to finance themselves
because
competition to the moral worldview
that's being presented in black lives
matter and antifa
uh is being attacked you know it's just
being attacked for
being in opposition to this at this
point so
you these people definitely need support
but it is also worth
um trying to go past the idea of police
reform because
essentially you can be like well there
are many ways to skin a cat right
like i might i might want police reform
too but i don't think defunding the
police is the way to get police reform
so i'm gonna you know i have a different
idea for that which might be
and i mean there are lots of ideas like
in america some like 70
of the police don't police their own
districts that they live in so they're
from out of town
they've come that's you know that's you
can see why that would be
a concern right so you might want police
reform so it's like you know
70 percent do police their own districts
or something like that you know
so there are other ways to get um to
resolve
issues and there are issues to be
resolved um
but i guess you know you just have to
have these
very difficult conversations if you want
but you'll probably get disavowed very
quickly
like i love i i absolutely adore having
having nuanced conversations this is
what i would spend my entire time doing
trying to work out exactly where the
truth lies this
isn't this interesting but again like
the things that we need
to talk about the most are precisely the
things that we can't talk about
and it makes that's what scares me
because i'm like i don't know
whether i'm going to say something which
yesterday was reasonable
and yet today is a landmine and as you
can see with
we should pull this show down off tv we
should do this
you're talking about some shows like uh
once upon a time in hollywood that are a
year old
you're talking about something where the
rules have changed because i
maybe people were up in arms i don't
know but i didn't see people being up in
arms when that film came out it got a
bunch of big accolades got a huge
director behind it quentin tarantino and
blah blah
and i'm like i have conversations for a
living
this is what i do for hours and hours
per week as do you
perhaps you're if you slightly bigger
pair of brass balls than i do
but my point is that as someone who is
like a professional conversationalist
i am real scared about
about some of the conversations that i
want to have
i want to have these conversations
because i think that they're worthy
because i think they're interesting
because we are absolutely living through
history like oh my god
like if 2020 isn't some history for you
there like i don't know
what it is yeah i think it's probably
going to have a lot more written on it
than the early 2000s
but um yeah no you are you are right i
mean
this is why i've been in such consistent
opposition to this world view for such a
long time
because it was eminently uh demonstrable
from the small spaces in which it taken
over that it very rapidly becomes
tyrannical
it imposes a kind of regime of terror on
people and
lo and behold now that it's taken over
the mainstream culture which i said that
it would i said this was coming
now it's taken it over now everyone
feels afraid
like you can see people like uh robin
deangelo was on jimmy fallon the other
day and
uh the top reply to the tweet that had
the video on it is you look like a
hostage
and it's like yes he does because if he
says something wrong he's getting
cancelled and he's never coming back
because there's no amount of forgive
there's no method of forgiveness or
penance
with this religion especially when
status can be assumed by simply
attacking
someone who's morally inferior you know
while while you can
raise yourself up by doing nothing else
and tearing other people down you're
never going to be safe
you're never going to be safe that's why
i've been wanting about this
um look kyle it's been uh a year since
you were on i have to give you as well
as a parting note
i have to give you a very big thank you
for coming on last year it was a huge
help to the channel
it's been a big part of the growth um
and i i couldn't appreciate you more for
for coming back on uh teespring is that
the only place that we can get you now
uh no no no spreadshirt now you are
kidding me
you got banned from a t-shirt site yeah
but
it wasn't for political reasons they
they they
i'd i'd done a parody of a star wars
logo
uh well i hadn't done it but you know
we've done a parody of a star wars
t-shirt
and they were like no no that violates
copyright or it might do
so we're like okay fine we'll take it
down and then like two weeks later they
brought it back up again accused me of
re-uploading it which i hadn't
and then we're like yep that's it and
it's like right okay so i don't think it
was about that
i think it was actually about politics
the most demonetized man
so where can people go they want to find
out more when should they do stuff now
they they can just um search for a cad
daily a double k a d
daily uh but i'll i'll have uh something
i'll have my own site in a few months
hopefully so
but i'll let everyone know through my
youtube channel where to go
amazing thank you very much for your
time mate thanks very much man